[Applaudissements]
ça va être bizarre de l'udinese si on
fait un muscle du clic de ce congrès
organisé les attaques aux oiseaux est
peu visible à s'adapter au changement
[Applaudissements]
avec la sagesse veut pas les adapter au
changement arrive à tomber le mage et 16
la vie chère qui cherchent à manger le
refus de coppé la hauteur
il s'adapte à ces changements alors
j'aimerais que tout un chacun blague
lisbonne et essaie de se rappeler une
règle avant lorsque nous étions tous
multi vous refuserez pas vous sinon la
plupart je leur aurais vraiment c'était
devenu pilote lorsque je voyais les
avions je disais à l appui que les
américains sauront par la rigole en la
passant soit sûr et qu'il disparaît au
profit d'andré ou en eaux profondes à
mes clients ont surmonté de mourir
celle de nbc avant les deux indices ont
progressé de 12 ans donc je suis appelé
à me former les ceintures et elle tout
ça juste alterné interminable du hamas
le bac est agressé un père me voir je me
voyais
une série jugement et valait encore et
toujours alerte à ces changements
elle vient choisi j'ai chanté avec les
parents les charges avec les émissions à
l'avenir grossesse je considère que j'ai
commencé donc je me suis réveillé mer la
portabilité
au début cela dit si le crédit je serai
au ministre en résine et un jour je suis
assise et je vous supposez a déjà mis en
rang et chandhok est ce que je vais tu
as peur de moi au vu et au su me ravit
je suis aux radiations
face à ce qui va arriver non je n'ai pas
peur de ma pauvre et c'est là que je me
suis en vacances et s'adapter au
changement lensois un objectif dans son
verre après le but et résoudre vient de
quelque chose
du peu que j'ai vécu la première des
choses c'est que quand on veut vraiment
sale aviez un changement il faut laisser
pour desserrer sa place je disais que
j'aimerais bien en bourse avec lui c'est
tout sauf à une charnière parce que
justement
et marginal et c'est cette course contre
il est jeune et c'est de ce soir quand
tu parles graphisme au moins j'ai réussi
ces changements il fallait que je prenne
le drame de bruit que nous avons
beaucoup d'amis aux sources mêmes choses
il s'agirait du but
j'ai même eu le temps de découvrir la
prescription les romancières comptes et
des comptables
j'ai vu les soldats je me suis rendu
plus difficile le départ si si vous
verrez que c'est romantique à l'époque
c'était juste un coup d'arrêt dans les
pc et sauver des vies s'était amélioré
le guen est le berceau et s qui est par
contre je ne pouvais pas faire les
choses
arashi we love un cheval entre le
cyclisme à le blesser
l'entreprise a besoin de crédit et voir
si je vous kiffe divers thèmes disent
qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent car je serai
toujours été un plaisir des autobus à
jeudi un contrat lui diront qu'il mènera
à la modernise et ghazi la dezir ali
s'était marié à raser rising
je voulais réaliser d'ici dix ans et a
suivi
je reste à paris d'ici là je pense
beaucoup à voir vos goûts vos y aura du
mal à enlever de volailles et oiseaux
les jeux mais l'institution qui choisit
remaniement les conseilleurs municipaux
les nazis puis seuls 10 des revenus est
arrivé à dakar
reconverti en civil avaient tiré par
l'innovation dire que je veux oublier la
formation l organe allait devoir est
bien connu c'est de rester sur le
terrain afin d'y voir figurer à robert
king au ras mais aussi aura pas avant 12
ou 15 charnières
a gerland c'est le grès louise est tout
d'abord une et d'imagination et de
diffuser les photocopies un programme
prévu mais m intéresse et permettez moi
même parce que le coût de l'abbatiale et
aussi uns et les autres parce que
c'était les étudiants ont bénéficié de
ses coutures à l'origine assez large et
quelque chose
la station sera même plus une ombre sur
la rue main les exploits
c'est souvent le cas en étudiant la
beaucoup d'intérêt pour cette version 10
1 à 0
et là je me suis rendu compte que je ne
vienne à brûler les ailes aux grandes gt
pour un confort de brûler par la plaçant
la chaîne en sus province avait des
envies ont fait plaisir aux autres
je dis pas qu'ils aient roulé mais je
suis parti les parallèles sont les bras
prendre pour réaliser quelques jours se
développer aujourd'hui l'ensemble est à
rien ou tic valley désignant ce rapport
à l'inertie au pk12 nous il ya la vie
associative permet de développer des
compétences et leurs ados canaris qui
permet de trouver le bon rythme
aujourd'hui on est sur des bases
arrières alors je ne veux pas brûler les
opportunités que j'avais pour un confort
obligés marielle age origins est arrivé
il se décide le monde ici hazard a
fabriqué des objets tous cheminer des
moyens d'agir a dit que je ne pouvais
plus marcher parler de toujours bien a
fourni près de 3 leur objectif
le repenti qui se passait vraiment
s'adapter à tout ce qui est arrivé à
pied cet objectif au comptoir air forcé
est très possible
nous avons renforcé au grand jour à
ramener vers la tasmanie et et la bouche
est depuis revenu il s'agirait vraiment
confiance et génère beaucoup les autres
les gens
visite est vraiment foncer je voulais
s'est pas passé ainsi un beau coup
d'état nation doit l'adaptation nous
avons nous mêmes le football
les femmes les hommes ya beaucoup de
tentations
il restait pour sa décision de refus
c'est la fonderie a servi de sucettes
arrive à pardonner à succès les gones
menaient d'un but ou à moi
la diva ne pouvait m'arriver pourquoi
toi tu ne pourras valeo courtois tué
doivent allier
je suis les évolutions un objectif on
disait que le débat social bon je
faisais mario niveau offensif et à la
vie associative mais c'est pas suffisant
on ne leur a jamais eu marre son amour
il rigole
après tout ça va rires mais c'est vrai
c'est vraiment une erreur parce que
j'étais concentré sur l'objectif
aujourd'hui je voudrais d'abord de joie
aussi j'ai dû faire des sacrifices
ce sera au juge de ligne l'a dit alain
dinin lors du tunnel viger dsk est
finalement formation aussi d'un projet
s'est ravisé sujet clos gérard géron
tina maze à elles vont être obligés
aujourd'hui trois finales plutôt pas mal
et j'ai arrêté d'autres j'ai pu avoir
raison tout dit et tout ça j'ai étudié
plus le train à fribourg c'est le voir
sous un autre et dans les études et j'ai
pu attaquer aux différentes situations
qui se voudrait avoir l'arrivée massive
obligé mais au final on imagine is a lie
à des monnaies par une
je ne connais vraiment des places ont
également subit donc je dois aussi
profiter de cette nouvelle merci à ces
personnes le paternel et mois et de 0,9
seulement 0 isr fsb lors des chaleurs et
j'ai dû arrêter la guerre de man à l
amateurisme
je viens d'avoir cédé à des niveaux du
sud est guère marché celle ci n'a pas
marché il fallait faire arrêter l'emploi
et une éthique et sur la ligne droite
pour les gauchers et c'est aussi ça la
chance de se voir dérouler au second
arrêté par le corps du regard dans le
rétroviseur car il a des regrets
selon son contenu du journal hürriyet le
26 nov je n'agis sûr de tous les succès
d'evans rédigé n'oubliera ainsi qu'à
passer de l'idée à la houppe nous avons
l'un plutôt la manière dont je vois les
cicatrices du passé
le détail par là où nous allons plutôt
rare dans cet été et la route ou qui
représente le plus cette joie les avait
du travail que j'avais accompli c'est
celle là
[Applaudissements]
un petit régal oui je suis aussi de
cette joie est immense pour moi voudrait
pas revenu au jeu et je ne sais pas
pourquoi je pense que tout le monde ce
projet pèse aujourd'hui où on arrive à
atteindre ses objectifs de remontée qui
se passe et je regardais la télé je sais
pas moi c'est les séparer de cette
classe j'étais assez bon gta blues
devraient savoir libanaise elle prêt à
foncer foncer tête baissée renard avant
à moins de 12 erreurs en traitant des de
bruit tout changement tout ce programme
à ce quizz nous sommes précisément à vis
de lui ne dépend pas du goût du jour peu
changé vous parlez parlez c02 cette
précipitation à sauter les autorités et
lévinas vous grand juillet de notre
chemin et enfin de s'arrêter au ralenti
regardez votre viseur ils vont aussi
clairement j'ai régulièrement marcher
vous continuez à des bourses ou
minérales
[Applaudissements]